this weekend i saw something absolutely
insane on the internet and i think that
you should pay attention to this so
first it all started with a tweet from
president biden here in the tweet he
said under my predecessor the deficit
increased every single year this year
we're on track to cut the deficit by 1.5
trillion dollars the biggest one-year
decline ever it matters to families
because reducing the deficit is one of
the main ways we can ease inflationary
pressures then from there there was a
random twitter account that quote
tweeted it and seemed pretty innocent
and here they said this is so silly
deficit is decreasing because we're not
doing pandemic aid anymore and federal
receipts are up because of inflation
congress or the biden administration
didn't do anything to lower the deficit
now this just looks like a casual dunk
from a suit anonymous account on twitter
but here's where it gets really
interesting jeff bezos one of the
richest people in the world he got on
twitter and he quote tweeted the quote
tweeter bezos came in hot and he said in
fact the administration tried hard to
inject even more stimulus into an
already overheated inflationary economy
and only mansions save them from
themselves inflation is a regressive tax
that most hurts the least affluent
misdirection doesn't help the country
now i've got two major takeaways from
jeff bezos's tweet the first is that the
absolute worst nightmare for politicians
is if some of the best entrepreneurs of
our lifetime are armed with twitter
accounts and they're not scared to speak
their mind having jeff bezos come in and
do this it's quite embarrassing for the
current administration regardless of
whether you like jeff bezos or you don't
or even if you agree with him or not if
all of a sudden the jeff bezos and the
elon musks start to actually put out in
public their thoughts it's gonna change
the conversation and my prediction is
that we're gonna see the pendulum swing
back in favor of capitalism business and
the idea that businesses startups and
capitalism actually solves hard problems
the second takeaway i had was that bezos
is actually right here he starts talking
about the fact that while inflation was
raging on the current administration
actually did want to inject more
liquidity into the market and ultimately
inflation ends up hurting those who
don't understand it the people who are
in the most dire financial position in
the entire country they're the ones who
are hurt by inflation 45 percent of
americans have no investable assets and
inflation is absolutely punishing them
so jeff bezos is right here we must
either educate these people or we must
get inflation down the ideal scenario
would actually do both at the same time
now of course we're never going to get
any sort of reconciliation of this we
won't get any admission of guilt from
politicians but what we are seeing is a
sea change where the best entrepreneurs
in the world they have those twitter
accounts they no longer think it's off
limits for them to actually voice their
private opinions and what my guess is is
they're going to apply pressure and lots
of it to many of the politicians many of
the elected officials and also the
central bankers to get inflation under
control to not push america into a
recession and to simply allow the free
markets to do their job now ultimately
we're gonna see how long it takes for
that to occur and i wouldn't hold my
breath but seeing jeff bezos starting to
tweet i for one am enjoying it and i
tend to think that between him and musk
we're gonna see many many more
successful entrepreneurs start to do the
same exact thing hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time